good morning believe nation today's
message is impose your will over to you
inky johnson you know what people quit
people don't have pride in what they do
you know what people stop they're
selfish and it's just about them when
you have a bigger purpose to why you're
doing what you're doing and you want to
honor your sacrifices that others have
made for you it's nothing for you to
keep going when you hear that versity if
every decision and choice you make is
just about you at a certain point you're
going to hit something that's a lot
tougher than you and it's going to make
you quit because you don't have a
driving force for why you do what you do
but when I got up to the University of
Tennessee it was simple and was simple
for me to give everything I had my
freshman year I played special routines
my sophomore season I built the starting
lineup had a really strong sophomore
season and some we're heading into my
junior year I still remember the day
where I was sitting in our film room and
I was watching film on the California
bears my defensive backs coach Larry
Slade came in the room he said inky I
got some good news for you
I dropped the click I said what is it he
said man you projected top 30 draft
picks huh he said all you have to do is
play the next 10 football games your
automatic multi-million in I went out of
the room I called my mother my
grandmother on a threeway I said after
this season there will be no more
struggle I said we would never miss
another man
I said we would never experience another
Christmas where we have to stand on the
side of the curve and just be grateful
now hum get up first football game I
went out played great got an
interception check Cal down second game
weekend against air force got late in
the game for Florida God dropped back he
threw the ball to receiver coming down
my sideline man a guy we went head-on as
soon as I hit the guy felt as if every
breath of my body left body went
completely left fell to the ground I
blacked out never happened to me my eyes
open I'll never forget my teammates ran
over they said ain't get up let's go I
said I can't I can't move said what do
you mean you can't move it y'all locked
down corner man we need you let's go I
said I know man but this time I can't
move I flipped my head up to the sky see
God said surely nothing has happened in
this moment that can alter my life
it got me over to the hospital he took
me back they ran cat-scans they brought
me back into my room and all in a
15-second timeframe the doctor came
running in from the opposite side he
said hey get in here we gotta watch this
guy back to emergency surgery he's about
to die I said what he said son you have
busted up subclavian artery in your
chest you're bleeding internally we have
to rush you back take the main vein out
of your left leg plug it into your chest
in order to save your life when I open
my eyes from recovery the same doctors
over he says son has some good news and
some bad news for you I said you got
some bad news for Matt to tell him I was
about to die I'm still alive how bad can
it get I'm still here he said the good
news is we saved your life I said thank
you sir he said the bad news is ain't
gonna have nerve damage in your right
shoulder I said okay cool
he said my son is a strong possibility
that you probably can never play the
game of football again in your life I
said no way I said no disrespect to you
doc but I've been working for this ever
since I was seven years old I said no
disrespect to you doc but you wasn't in
the park with me and my mother now was
seven years old she was sitting in that
Buick we got that she got done working
at Wendy's no disrespect to you doc but
you didn't come up and had to back when
114 people sleeping on the floor no
disrespect to you doc but you'd have
missed those meals and stay focused and
never made an excuse
I never cheated I never cheated like my
conscience still until his day won't let
meet you like I can't cheat
I can't look myself in the mirror and
say eat you did a good job knowing that
I cheat I can't cheat what are the
greatest pieces of advice that my mother
gave me was this son whenever you start
you make sure you finish and the problem
with the world today people get involved
with things and if they don't like a
certain person if they don't like the
process if it's not what they thought it
was they quit and what they don't
understand about quitting quitting me
humping becomes a habit that doesn't
disinfect you later on in life will you
get a wife and you get some kids or you
get a family it's going to come back to
haunt you and then when one day affects
them that is why I tell you the process
is more important than the product it's
not even about the outcome for me it's
about can you take pride in what you do
as an individual and every night when
you look in the mirror knowing that you
gave everything you add to it and we
have to get to the point where we're
willing to impose our will on certain
things impose your will on it my life
totally changed and they gave me an
opportunity to stop and most people when
you give them an opportunity to stop
while they're chasing something they
take advantage of it because they feel
as if man why does this have to happen
to me I felt as if why not me this is
the perfect opportunity to use this to
be a blessing than somebody else and you
know what it's not even about me to be
truthful it's not even about me now it's
about repaying the people that invested
in me and saw something in me when I
couldn't see it in myself at a certain
point in life it can't just be about you
in the moment that we understand that
and every day we wake up we understand
that life is a blessing and life is a
gift and if you were to check out today
how would you want to be remembered it's
bigger than you so first off this is an
amazingly powerful clip I had never
heard of Enki before doing the research
for this video and so whoever of you
guys in believe nations suggested that
we do him I am grateful thank you so
much I'm expecting a powerhouse of a top
ten coming on Enki my quick thoughts on
this is I'm a big believer in in the
army of one and that's where I will will
something into existence and so when I'm
starting off a new project that I'm
passion
that I want to see come to life that I
have this idea that maybe other people
think is crazy I'm going to will it into
existence I am going to make it happen
and at the start
I'll involve people and say hey do you
want to join me what do you think do you
want to be a part of this try to build
up a team and if they come on board
amazing and we'll build this thing
together and if they don't if they don't
like it they don't see how they can fit
they don't want to help out I will be an
army of one and will it into existence I
will make it happen
and as we get a little more success than
I can afford to hire somebody to come on
and help me if you don't want to join me
and partner up at the beginning that's
okay you singing no you telling me how
stupid something is you telling me how
it's not going to work does not impact
my willingness to go it and do it and I
think that's where most people fall
short you are living your life too much
from the expectations and beliefs of
other people whether that's your family
your friends people around you your
parents whoever doctors you're living
your life according to the opinions and
beliefs of other people instead of
setting the standards so high for
yourself that it doesn't matter what the
people on the knee think if you set your
standards for up here and everybody else
expects you to play here then even when
you fall short you're harder on yourself
that anybody else can be on you you know
if I'm late for a meeting that might
upset somebody you know that person that
I'm meeting I'm way harder on myself
than they are ever going to be because I
hate being late for a meeting there's a
new potential instructor I'm looking at
for my dance studio and she really badly
wants to become an instructor and she's
on her path and she's learning and
growing and developing the skills to be
able to do that and she goes home when
she tells her her family hey I want to
be an instructor here I think I can make
an impact and her sister the first thing
that she tells her her sister tells her
that she can't do it
her sister tells her that she's not good
enough that who is she to think that she
can be an instructor and teach dance and
for a lot of people that's the end right
for a lot of people they give up they
quit they're done because your sister
thinks you can't do it therefore you
think you can't do it and so you
and in life along the path to any goal
that you're trying to accomplish you're
gonna hit tons of roadblocks tons of
roadblocks the challenge is the process
of overcoming those and if you don't
believe in what you've got you're always
going to be subject to the opinions of
other people
if you quit on your dance dream because
your sister says you're not good enough
then you're always just living up to
your sisters expectations for what you
can do as opposed to what you want to do
and it sucks not to get your sister
support or your parents support or your
bestfriend support but it doesn't matter
you don't need their support to be you
you don't need their support to be the
greatest version of yourself you don't
need their support to go and build your
dreams their opinion of you does not
impact your self-confidence does not
have an impact on your self-worth if you
guys love my videos that's amazing
if you guys hate my videos I don't care
can I take feedback on how to make them
better 100% but if you don't like me the
way I talk the way I look to what I'm
doing doesn't matter to me if you're
constantly living your life by the
opinions of other people you're never
going to go out and live your dreams and
so it's great to involve people it's
great to get expert opinions it's great
to tell friends and family and if
they're supportive and understand you
they can give you resources and
knowledge and mentorship and advice and
guidance
amazing and if they can't if they're
either apathetic and they don't care
about it or worse than negative and just
trash your idea doesn't matter
you're gonna will it into existence
you're gonna be an army of one because
this is your dream and you can't blame
anybody else for you not chasing your
dream if you don't go out and hit it
it's not your sister's fault
it's not your mom's fault it's not your
best friend's fault it's your fault so
own it be an army of one and will it
into existence so the question of the
day today is I'm curious what have you
had the will into existence
something that everybody told you was
crazy would never work you have no shot
and you just made it happen I want to
hear your story share it leave it down
in the comments below I also want to
give a quick shout out to Cammy Anna
Jardine thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word I really
really really really appreciate it thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
Press